hi I'm Jeff Bergsma a Google engineer
and I'd like to announce an exciting new
algorithm that could predict a film's
box office success with 94% accuracy
it's called Google blockbuster simply
upload your movie trailer to Google
blockbuster hit return and in a few
seconds our algorithm queries a series
of data points related to the film data
such as how many dimensions is it what
is the acreage of any oncoming asteroids
is Tim Allen in the film how many blocks
has the director bussed in the past are
any stars trekked Wardour danced with
have you at least considered Tim Allen
how many years past the optimal ages the
protagonist getting for this [ __ ] what
is the lowest common Wayans brother if
Tim Allen isn't in the film why not
has he read the script how many messages
did you leave with his manager what is
the weddings to funerals ratio how dirty
is the film's dancing on a scale of
sterile to grotesque
how Chandar the film's Jackie's and/or
Tatum's is their synchronic reliability
between the film's fastness its fury
ASSA tea and its diesel essence
have you tried luring Tim Allen with
non-monetary perks maybe a nice leather
chair from the Pottery Barn
I hear he shops there we then take the
answers to all of those questions
discard them and just record the
viewcount of your trailer on YouTube and
that gives us a pretty good indication
94%
[Music]
google blockbuster busting it